[Música]
bueno pues voy a hablar de evolución es
el leitmotiv de esta edición 2021 de
télex actual
la primera es la espiral emergente en la
espiral pues es un símbolo de nuestra
vida de nuestra evolución en cada
escalón ahí están las marcas de la vida
en nuestras vivencias nuestros
aprendizajes lo que somos es por los
dones que hemos heredado de nuestros
padres y por lo que hemos aprendido en
la vida en la vida como la espiral nos
cierra la espiral es continua hasta que
muere o dejamos de aprender si implosión
es el núcleo llegarías más allá de tus
padres de tus ancestros hasta el origen
mismo de la vida lo que continúa que
respirar que no vemos y respirar lo
emergente que es lo que continuo es el
futuro es el misterioso devenir como
vida nietzsche es lo que tenemos por
vivir son nuestras experiencias y es el
aprendizaje que está ahí para nosotros
para construirnos
y la segunda es el monolito de cubre que
es es un símbolo eso justamente cubre y
claro para hablar de momentos que
gatillan la evolución en la humanidad
tiene planeta en la primera vez que los
ojos que en esta película desde aquí yo
creo que nadie la vio porque se hizo en
los sesentas 2001 odisea en el espacio'
lo usa fue visualizando sale un homínido
que lo pone del pulgar aprende ha sido
objetos a manipularlos y los convierte
en de herramientas y en armas y eso le
da una ventaja competitiva que lo pone
en la punta de la ventana trófica hasta
arriba o sea dominamos el mundo cuando
aprendimos a poner el pulgar hay otros
momentos como cuando aprendemos a
manejar el fuego la rueda el vapor la
electricidad la combustión enfrenta
en este momento no sé si lo ven y hay un
monolito este monolito empieza con el
cambio de milenio en el tercer milenio
en el 2012 cuando el calendario maya se
resetea a cero y empieza la segunda dama
ya ahí empieza este monolito algunas
características notables es el internet
la evolución del internet otra es la
pandemia que más bien es la cuarentena
que es la sanación que es adquirir como
humanidad un mayor nivel de conciencia
para cambiar el rumbo de lo que es de lo
que está pasando y de lo que estamos
haciendo estamos frente a un monolito y
el monolito viene acompañado de
pecho se alterna el caos la entropía y
el orden
de hecho caos no es una mala palabra
caos es un orden complejo que todavía no
entiendo
o sea es algo que no entiendo por qué se
toman esas decisiones porque se hace lo
que hace porque pasa lo que pasa el
orden absoluto para lisa y el caos
absoluto destruye entonces la idea se
encontraron un balance no en donde el
sufrimiento se da por la resistencia y
acá me resisto a cambiar el otro día vi
a un colega que anunció con bombo y
platillo un curso que se llamaba
el mundo post kobe el regreso a la
normalidad
seguimos en el mundo kobe y seguiremos
y ahora regreso en normalidad nueva
normalidad sí en lo que nos adaptamos
pues vamos a sufrir el camino esas arroz
sobre todo si no tenemos un método el
tercer icono de que quiero hablar tiene
que ver con las manos las alas es la
característica notable de las aves para
volar las aletas de los peces para nadar
las piernas las largas de los cheetahs
para correr a gran velocidad de los
humanos las manos
las manos no somos los mejores corriendo
no somos los más fuertes somos los
mejores que aprendiendo y evolucionar
las cucarachas tienen las mismas formas
que tenían hace 500.000 años el ser
humano evoluciona más rápido y la
característica notable del humano son
las manos que le dan nombre a la especie
y manos
de dos manos humanos
la mano es la parte flexible del cuerpo
se adapta al otro se ajusta es dura como
un puño y suave como una caricia puede
tocar el cielo y labrar la tienda
también
es la polaridad humberto maturana que en
paz descanse dice que la mano es el
instrumento del amor
porque se adaptan y las manos representa
esta nuestra capacidad de evolucionar
bueno digital de dos manos muchas
personas piensan que digital tiene que
ver con tecnología tiene que ver con
personas digital de dos manos humanos
y aquí viene la historia es una historia
de quiebre personal se llama la 48 así a
secas fue un monolito que me sucedió
cuando tenía 12 años
vivía en caracas venezuela- mi papá
decidió que nos mudamos a mexico eso me
llenó de alegría porque yo era mexicano
a los 12 años y no conocía méxico
mi papá un poco para motivarme me mandó
esa postal esa postal que es la ver
olímpica de ciudad universitaria como mi
pasión era nadar o sea representaba a mi
colegio en competencias de natación gané
muchas medallas cuando era joven
entonces dije no yo espero estar ahí yo
quiero ir a méxico y de hecho
cuando llegue a méxico fue increíble
todo me encantó la ciudad los taxis la
torre latino las palabras este no
extrañaba para para nada ni los tontos
ni las arepas
me costó un poco de trabajo algunas
cosas algunas palabras por ejemplo el
punto decimal ya no era una coma sino
era un mundo y además a los mexicanos
nadie les dijo lo que da una lechosa
nadie les dijo lo que dan cara a otras
con azúcar
entonces empecé a como hay que tener ahí
un primer quiebre y las palabras de las
ciudades seeds y panda kuri o sea para
cuando me aprendí eso planteé lógico
tlalnepantla
imagínate eres venezolano y vienes a dar
un test a cuatro años y vienes por la
carretera y ves el letrero
ya te pasaste al caso
entré a la secundaria no había albergue
para empezar
de pasé de ser el representativo
colegial del exclusivísimo colegio san
agustín del paraíso hacia el más pequeño
y más goleado de la secundaria porque
además tiene acento mención jarocho el
sí con los peones bien
entonces éste lo que aprendí lo que les
aprendí fue a nadar no volví a nadar y
aprendí a defenderme en el barça en lo
más bajo del barrio ahí aprendí a
defender esta competencia me sirvió
muchísimo después porque años después
fue jugador de fútbol americano crecí
como 30 centímetros este año cumplimos
50 años de uno de mis equipos de la
infancia de la adolescencia
ahí me servía defenderme pero no nada
entonces la pregunta que me dice pues
ahora de qué me sirve nada en este
momento en este monolito de qué me sirve
defenderme
se te atraviesa un taxista ustedes a que
en cuanto a cual no saben de eso se te
atraviesa un taxista lo gente amoroso es
decirle buen hombre por favor pase sacas
la ventana le das la bendición pero no
me sale la 48 o de qué sirve para qué
ahora vivo en un pueblo muy pequeño en
tepoztlán y cuando muere un ciudadano
nativo le hacen un cortejo fúnebre que
abarca las dos los dos carriles y las
banquetas entonces si te atrapa ya
estuviste una hora en la procesión
entonces tienes dos opciones o actúas
como eres o te aprendes en la espiral
emergente o sea tienes una nueva
competencia
entonces o te arrebatas que es lo que
sea servir o acompañase al muertito al
difunto a su última moda hasta le hasta
le das una oración
6 claves para evolucionar sin sufrir
demasiado que no incluye ni nadal ni
arrebatarse
amarse a sí mismos es lo primero ponerte
en primer lugar tu propósito personal
tiene que ver contigo no con los demás o
sea yo estoy aquí no por ustedes sino
por mí estoy aquí por mí es un poco
egoísta tal vez me amo me respeto me
cuido honro mi linaje aprendo de mí en
la espiral emergente muy complicado
amarse a sí mismo es una competencia por
lo tanto se aprende
o sea hay que aprender a amarse quien se
ama a sí mismo está habilitado para amar
a los demás
quien sabe amar sabe comprar sino no
sabes cómo relacionarte con los demás
por lo menos desde el amor es la primera
clave la segunda es vivir con propósito
ya les dije mi propósito personalísimo
es experimentar la vida desde el amor
pero me gusta pensar que mi propósito
está conectado con un propósito superior
con un propósito colectivo en este caso
mi propósito individual de experimentar
la vida está conectado con mi propósito
social que es mi mejor versión mi
talento al servicio de la cocreación al
servicio de los demás
la co-creación de un mundo mejor y eso a
la vez está conectado con el propósito
de la humanidad que es nutrir el suelo
que pisa el aire que respira
el agua que bebe y eso a su vez está
conectado con el propósito del planeta
que es albergar la vida la tercera clave
es liderar la evolución y esto les va a
gustar cambio es lo que sucede y sucede
lo que sucede quedamos o no sucede que
hay una pandemia sucede que hay una
tormenta
en cambio evolución es lo que provoca es
lo tuyo
esto son tus proyectos es la historia
que estás construyendo en tu vida o lo
que estás haciendo con tu vida
eso es liderar la evolución ágil en un
mundo frágil la palabra ágil es la que
va a definir esta tercera década este
monolito que tenemos enfrente va a durar
la década completa o sea no es algo que
se acaba el 17 de abril es algo que va a
durar 10 años en el ajuste en lo que
comprendemos el nuevo orden porque toca
observar es escudriñar toca formular
preguntas que iluminen no contestar
preguntas que ya nadie se formula
digitalizar tu mundo acuérdense dígito
de los dedos manos manos humanos
digitalizar es humanizar
tiene que ver más la evolución digital
con la persona que con la tecnología
el quinto si si las anteriores no
sirvieron o no les parecen
esta es la panacea la quinta es usar la
sílaba o cada vez que tengas una
encrucijada cada vez que tengas una
decisión cada vez que vas a impactar al
mundo encuentra palabras que empiecen
con coma
yo suelo persignarme cuando tengo un
momento importante como hoy coco
empieza con tu corazón empieza con como
entonces me persigno con estómago
corazón páncreas y en el besito íntegro
y lo que haga y sobre todo lo que diga
va a ser inteligente y amoroso
aquí aquí hay otras no con conmigo
contigo consenso colaborar conversar
coach cooperar colaborar a que hay 24
palabras podrían ser 100
la cuando vaya a nacer aquí está la
solución
yo tengo el sueño de que hay un
despertar colectivo ya que haya un
incremento en la conciencia sobre todo
después de la cuarentena que nos lleve a
otro nivel de darme cuenta y sobre todo
hacer meter para revertir el desastre
antropogénico que el hombre ha causado
sobre la faz de la tierra
está cañón estamos en el filo de la
navaja la humanidad en su mejor versión
pues es arte hacemos cosas maravillosas
puentes libros poesía
pero somos plana cuando robamos
nos consumimos de más de sol estamos
tumbamos un árbol nos convertimos en una
plaga estamos al filo de la navaja o la
humanidad realmente tiene un incremento
en el nivel de conciencia derivado de
esta cuarentena por la humanidad
condenada lo cual es triste porque lo
que verán nuestros hijos y nietos que
nosotros no vendemos hoy por hoy es
ciencia ficción o sea ni siquiera nos lo
podemos imaginar cubre no se imaginó
este momento por ejemplo
en la espiral emergente
está la oportunidad de mi generación de
nuestra generación de hacer algo por el
planeta también están las posibilidades
y sobre todo nuestro doble tra
la evolución es un proceso que cambias
de aquí para
estoy aquí que no estaba esa es la
situación actual es la situación deseada
el miedo lo convierto en movimiento el
enojo la molestia en la frustración la
desesperanza la convierto en posibilidad
la posibilidad que tiene mi generación
es entregarle sano este planeta a las
nuevas generaciones que están aquí
presentes
muchas gracias coatzacoalcos
[Aplausos]